this episode is brought to you by
curiositystream
get free access to nebula the streaming
platform built by all your favorite
youtubers
when you sign up for curiosity stream at
the link below
[Music]
there is a shortage of skilled trades
people throughout the u.s
economy the department of labor reported
only 266 000 jobs were added in april
and the unemployment rate for the last
month ticked up to 6.1 percent
12 states have cut unemployment aid
about three months before
federal benefits expire in september at
the very moment that unemployment is
rising fewer people are working american
businesses say they can't find
employees and it's obvious they can't go
to the nearest strip mall and count the
help wanted signs on the doors they're
everywhere
if you've turned on the news within the
last couple months you've probably seen
all sorts of dramatic coverage and
special panels on the supposed labor
shortage that has cropped up in the wake
of the pandemic thanks to the covet
relief checks
tiny and inadequate as they were for the
first time in decades
many americans found themselves with the
tiniest bit of bargaining power against
their boss
suddenly they could afford to stay home
from their low-wage jobs
at least for a little while and many
took the opportunity to do so and look
for better employment
this led to a wave of posters and signs
outside places like mcdonald's saying
that
no one wants to work anymore as if it
were some kind of moral failing that
people were choosing not to slave away
over a griddle 10 hours a day for
poverty wages
but this new bit of tension between
workers and employers is just the tip of
the iceberg
in this episode we're going to explore
the possibility that the united states
is witnessing the birth of a new labor
movement
okay time for a pop quiz i'm going to
give you a quote
and you try to guess who said it here it
is labor is prior to
and independent of capital capital is
only the fruit of labor
and could never have existed if labor
had not first existed
labor is the superior of capital and
deserves much the higher consideration
who do you think made this assessment of
labor and capital
if you've seen my other videos you might
assume this is a quote by karl marx
but you'd be wrong this quote is
actually by none other than president
abraham lincoln from his 1861 state of
the union address
lincoln was a contemporary of marx and
there is some evidence to suggest that
the two may have even corresponded at
some point
but regardless the fact that a president
of the united states
a place we today consider the bastion of
free market capitalism
would make a statement so supportive of
labor over capital
is probably shocking to many of you
believe it or not the united states did
not always have the exploitative
soul-crushing labor landscape we see
today there was a time
many years ago now when workers had
actual bargaining power
where they could come together and say
to their boss hey we've got some demands
and the boss would have to work with
them today that kind of relationship
is nearly unthinkable the barest hint of
unionization in the workplace is often
grounds for termination
benefits our grandparents took for
granted have been stripped away
pensions vacation time paid sick days
maternity leave
a company car a fair wage all relics of
a bygone era
consumed by the all-devouring ideology
of cost cutting and maximizing profit
of course executives never feel the
sting of these measures
in fact their compensation has only
continued to grow
to the point where wealth inequality is
now just as bad as its peak during the
gilded age
these days many workers never even meet
their boss
they're not even considered employees
the gig economy has drastically changed
the way we look at work
and as of the latest available data 36
percent of american workers have turned
to gig work to make ends meet
combine the lack of livable wages
increasing rates of depression
lower life expectancy and rock bottom
job satisfaction rates with a global
pandemic
and you've got the perfect storm for a
renaissance of class consciousness and
labor activity
while it may not seem like much to the
untrained eye
over the past year we have seen workers
taking the very first steps towards
fighting for better conditions
one of the most important developments
has been the resurgence of the labor
strike in various industries as a tool
for forcing change
for example in 2020 during the pandemic
we saw strikes among nurses
teachers flight attendants and auto
workers to name just a few
in each of these instances the workers
typically unionized ones
formulated demands that would provide
them with better safety measures and
wage protection for the duration of the
pandemic
nurses unions picketed for adequate ppe
and better staffing to handle the
massive influx of coronavirus patients
teachers demanded that schools remained
closed until reasonable safety
precautions could be implemented to
protect themselves and their students
from contracting the disease and taking
it home to their families
auto workers forced the shutdown of
plants over social distancing concerns
flight attendants negotiated for
paycheck protection to be a part of the
industry bailout
ensuring their economic security through
the turbulent pandemic
in a time when millions of americans
were being laid off from work
many from jobs that would not survive
the pandemic union workers enjoyed a
certain level of protection thanks to
their bargaining power
and as such they were laid off at a
lower rate and often with job or
paycheck guarantees
this hasn't gone unnoticed after decades
of decline in union membership thanks to
vicious union busting campaigns and
expansion of corporate power
in 2020 membership began to tick up
again
2019 marked an all-time low for union
membership
with an abysmal 10.3 percent of workers
being represented by a union
in the wake of the pandemic that number
has climbed just a bit to 10.8 percent
while this may not seem significant it
represents the sharpest increase in 40
years
and the fact that it's increasing at all
after four decades of steep decline
is very promising this increase in
membership corresponds
with polling that indicates a majority
of americans see the decline of unions
as a bad thing for workers
and it coincides with the proliferation
of labor voices on social media
but we'll get to that in a minute one
important union action that's currently
ongoing
as of writing the script at least is the
impressive strike by alabama miners who
along with miners from several other
states traveled all the way to new york
city as a group to protest their unfair
treatment outside the blackrock
headquarters
blackrock is the primary shareholder of
warrior met coal
which operates out of brookwood alabama
warrior met miners have been on strike
for over four months now
demanding a fair contract after saving
the company from bankruptcy
back in 2016 when warrior met was in
danger of going under
miners accepted a six dollar per hour
pay cut to keep it afloat
since that time the company has
extracted record profits from their
operation
netting 309 million dollars in 2019
while the ceo continues to pocket his 4
million
salary all of this is on the backs of
the people who actually do the
incredibly hazardous
back-breaking unenviable work down in
the mines
of course this well-deserved strike has
garnered very little mainstream media
attention
one thing that's very important to note
is that class consciousness and
solidarity
the practice of standing with your
fellow workers does not necessarily
follow a cut and dry political divide
i'm sure there are plenty of fancy
business people in new york looking down
on the miners as a bunch of rednecks
not only their class enemy but opposed
to their preferred political team as
well
while it may be true that many of these
alabama miners espouse right-wing
politics in general
if you listen to their own words about
the strike you'll notice there's nothing
even the most centrist republican would
support
the united mine workers association
president said we're in new york city
because we're simply following the money
and demanding that those who created
that wealth the miners
get their fair share of it while abraham
lincoln would certainly have agreed with
that sentiment
modern politicians are opposed to it in
every way
both democrats and republicans have
fought tooth and nail to destroy unions
and make sure workers don't have any
bargaining power
in order to keep their corporate donors
happy and cutting them nice campaign
checks
the only group in america that supports
the striking workers
in just about any instance regardless of
industry is the socialists
what many people have historically seen
as a left-right divide
is understood by socialists as a capital
labor divide
the working class of the us is made up
of people from all political backgrounds
and their class interests are the same
regardless of those political beliefs
it's no coincidence that membership in
socialist groups like the dsa has been
increasing in tandem with union
membership
flowery words from politicians don't
mean much to striking workers
but actual material support from other
workers does
and the socialists are always the first
to lend a hand
specifically because of their
understanding of class struggle
the dsa is the largest organized
socialist group in the u.s
currently sitting just shy of a hundred
thousand dues-paying members
and since the pandemic that number has
jumped from 66 000 to its current 92
000. that is a massive increase in a
very short period of time
it just goes to show that when all
politicians have to offer is empty
promises
and an increasingly miserable capitalist
status quo
building an economic alternative starts
to sound pretty appealing
it's no wonder that polling continues to
show a decline in favorability for
capitalism
and an increase for socialism
politicians and the ultra wealthy seem
to be doing their very best to turn the
rest of us against them
for example amazon has been at the
center of worker rights discourse for a
while now
and instead of laying low jeff bezos
decides to go on a little joyride to
space while his workers literally die
on the job public perception has turned
decidedly against the ultra wealthy
and for good reason the only way they're
able to amass their vast fortunes is
through the exploitation of their
workers
and the problem continues to get worse
right now
there's still very little awareness of
the nature of class struggle
the battle between capital and labor
among the american people
those in power understand it that's why
unions have been all but destroyed since
the reagan years
the accumulation of ever greater profits
requires greater and greater extraction
from the laboring masses
without a banner to organize behind the
american working class lacks the
cohesion it needs to make effective
changes on a national scale
in the past it was socialist labor
leaders like eugene debs who offered a
path forward
and thanks to the bold actions of
workers back then we have many things we
take for granted today
child labor laws the weekend the eight
hour workday and 40-hour workweek
workplace safety laws and so much more
all of these were socialist initiatives
supported by millions of hard-working
americans with an understanding of class
struggle
the most critical thing we can do right
now is work towards rebuilding that lost
class consciousness
it will be a challenge but we have more
tools at our disposal than ever before
social media has proven an effective
tool for raising awareness and
coordinating labor actions
and as the younger generations who grew
up with the internet become more
politically active
we'll likely see social media play an
even larger role in organizing and
agitating for positive change
the dsa isn't perfect but it is a good
first step for getting involved and
learning
how to organize within your community
see if there's a local chapter
or if there's not reach out to the
national branch and start one yourself
if you've done the reading if you have a
good understanding of the mechanics of
class struggle
talk to your friends about it each one
teach one as the expression goes
every little bit helps and we need all
the help we can get
a new labor movement one that can really
force concessions from the ruling class
would drastically improve the lives of
average americans
it could afford us financial security it
could give us time to spend with our
friends and loved ones
and maybe if we're lucky it could even
make america the country it claims to be
a country that works for everyone not
just those with money and power
the labor market is constantly changing
finding new ways to extract value from
human energy
if we can organize for better conditions
now the future of work
might not be as terrible as the present
if you'd like to get a glimpse
of what that could look like i highly
recommend you check out work of the
future on curiositystream
it's a hopeful look at what kinds of
meaningful stimulating jobs could
replace our miserable current ones in
the coming decades
curiosity stream is an established
streaming platform with a solid track
record of caring about great educational
content and the financial security of
those who produce it
they've got thousands of non-fiction
titles from some of the best filmmakers
in the game
as you probably know youtube doesn't
treat its creators very well
that's why some of my youtuber friends
and i teamed up to build nebula
so we don't have to worry about
demonetization as educational creators
ourselves
we love curiositystream so we've worked
out a deal
where if you sign up for curiositystream
at the link below you'll also get access
to nebula
100 free that's less than 15 bucks a
year for both curiosity stream and
nebula
which in my humble opinion is a pretty
great deal since you're already on the
internet watching my video
why not spend some time learning about
fascinating topics on curiositystream
or check out nebula's original content
including my upcoming series on the
resurgence of fascism
you can also watch all my videos as they
were intended ad free
there really is something for everyone
and by signing up at the link below
you're helping us produce more content
without the fear of demonetization
give curiosity stream a shot and get
free access to nebula when you sign up
using the link below
it really does help support my channel
and educational creators all across
youtube
if you enjoyed this video and you'd like
to see more like it consider subscribing
to stay up to date with my latest
episodes
if you hated it go ahead and drop a
thumbs down you can check out my
previous episodes by clicking the links
on your screen
thanks for watching and i'll see you
next week